[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation le
secteur spatial qui recouvre les
satellites les stations des lanceurs et
les fournisseurs de services
n'est pas seulement un sujet pour les
scientifiques est un domaine stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaires c'est donc un
secteur d'avenir
dont la valeur totale d'après une étude
de morgan stanley devraient plus que
triplé en vingt ans passant de 350
milliards de dollars en 2010 est à 1100
milliards de dollars en 2004
bien sûr ceci explique l'intérêt des
entrepreneurs privés comme airbus ps qui
dans la suite d'elon musk se sont lancés
dans l'aventuré
parallèlement l'espace est devenu une
nouvelle dimension pour le militaire
dans tous les grands pays enfin il est
indiscutable qu'en termes d'image les
activités spatiales sont bénéfiques
chaque nouvelle avancée ayant un impact
positif pour celui qui l'a réalisé
pourtant
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale de
plus les progrès constants de la
recherche change les règles
nous en avons un bon exemple avec
l'évolution du lanceur européen dans la
compétition le coût d'achat d'ariane 6
va être 50% moins cher qu ariane 5 et il
est même prévu de gagner encore 20% de
compétitivité dans les prochaines années
à la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
les savants allemands concepteurs du v2
furent recrutés par les américains les
russes et français pour continuer leurs
travaux sur le spatial militaire et
civil avec leur aide
les russes réussir les premiers au delà
des missions militaires
à placer en 1957 un satellite dans
l'espace puis en 1962 youri gagarine en
orbite les américains priant le relais
en envoyant armstrong et aldrin sur la
lune et en lançant de grands programmes
d'exploration spatiale
interplanétaire et ce ropéen arrivait
ensuite grâce à des lanceurs de
satellites civils qui ont été il faut
bien le dire pendant une trentaine
d'années les plus performants
d'autant que les tirs se faisait d'une
plate forme de lancement idéale puisque
proche de l'équateur à kourou le lanceur
lourd ariane
fruit d'une collaboration européenne
organisée autour des français a détenu
jusqu'à 50% du marché mondial en 2009 de
2015 à 2020 c'est la société spe 6
d'elon musk qui a dominé le marché avec
son lanceur réutilisables falcon 9 qui
est évidemment moins coûteux mais en
2021 c'est le lanceur chinois l'on
marche qui a pris la tête en 2021 selon
anne bauer des échos il a été utilisé
48 fois contre trente et une pour le
falcon 10 au total les chinois ont
réalisé l'année dernière cinquante cinq
lancements spatiaux contre 45 aux etats
unis
25 pour la russie dont neuf pour
arianespace et 6 pour l'europe ainsi la
chine a représenté
38% des tirs contre 31% pour les
américains 17% pour les russes et 4%
pour les européens pour mémoire en 2020
il avait été procédé à 104 lancement
réussi à partir de neuf pays avec 10
échecs et en dehors des vols habités il
avait mis en orbite
12 172 satellite pour le compte de 41
pays différents
en dépit du lancement réussi il ya
quelques jours du télescope james webb
par une ariane 5 l'europe est donc en
difficulté d'une part le nouveau lanceur
ariane 6 qui sera lancée en 2022
n'ayant pas de premier étage
réutilisable est beaucoup plus cher que
son concurrent américain d'autre part
les italiens veulent produire une
nouvelle version de leur lanceur de
petits satellites la vega eux qui
pourrait récupérer 9 missions
institutionnelles
confié aujourd'hui ariane enfin les
allemands qui produisent déjà des petits
satellites supporte mal la direction
française du projet considérant que le
spatial leur revient historiquement de
droit vincent lamigeon dans challenges
nous informent qu'ils veulent construire
des micros lanceur à travers d'eau hb
hédi zar aerospace + monter rapidement
en gamme pour être l'opérateur derrière
cet essai pour contrer ces velléités que
le président macron annoncé récemment la
mise au point pour 2026 du projet
myspace visant à les concurrencer en
attendant le coordinateur du spatial
dans l'allemagne envisage la mise en
place d'une barge de lancement en mer du
nord pour concurrencer cours pendant que
les européens se battent entre eux la
chine développe une politique spatial
visant à faire jeu égal avec les états
unis elles assurent de nombreux
lancements de satellites pour son compte
et celui d'autres pays asiatiques et
développe des vols habités
faut bien le dire longtemps tenue par
les occidentaux comme négligeable dans
l'espace
elle est devenue en mai 2021
deuxième pays à faire évoluer sur mars
un petit robot après avoir été la
première en 2019 a posé plus à faire re
décoller un engin sur la face cachée de
la lune aujourd'hui elle est en train de
construire en dix étapes une station
spatiale la sixième étant en cours avec
trois astronautes
envoyé en octobre pour six mois et
l'objectif vers 2030 et d'envoyer des
chinois sur la lune puis d'y installer
avec les russes une base habitée à la
différence des américains qui ont
totalement séparé la partie militaire et
la partie civile qui l'ont laissée aux
entreprises privées en mettant à leur
disposition
toutes les connaissances de la nasa ou
des européens qui ont développé un
lanceur totalement civile les chinois
ont développé un programme à double face
civils et militaires
chez les américains la compétition entre
les entreprises privées est d'autant
plus forte que les principaux chefs
d'entreprises concernés comme musk bezos
ou bronson et investissent une partie de
leur fortune personnelle
il est vrai que c'est un secteur dans
lequel les valorisations au nasdaq sont
très élevés et les levées de fonds
spectaculaire ce qui facilite le
lancement des start up américaine du new
space ainsi
selon l'économiste pierre lyonnais space
x est valorisée plus de 80 fois sa
valeur réelle
ce qui la rend évidemment attractive
mais constitue une bulle explosive en
cas de problème de plus
selon une technique utilisée dans
l'armement et l'aéronautique
la nasa et la défense passe des
commandes institutionnelles qui assure
le financement des coûts fixes en
permettant aux industriels d'avoir à
l'export des prix plus compétitifs
on peut ajouter que les sociétés
américaine ne se contente pas d'envoyer
des fusées car elles sont régulièrement
partie prenante dans la production et
l'utilisation de satellites comme joseph
b dos et son projet clipper ou boeing
pour son projet de 147 satellite de
connexion internet pour la constellation
de satellites pour le haut niveau
starlink qui devrait lui rapporter selon
une étude de morgan stanley
22,8 milliards de dollars
space x a déjà mis en orbite
1700 satellite
et une fille danse ainsi la mise au
point de son lanceur géant starship qui
lui sera totalement réutilisables les
russes sont indiscutablement les plus
expérimentés avec les américains mais il
manque de moyens financiers pour le
spatial civil et l'évolution des
lanceurs dans le cas de roskosmos
il lançait cette élite
travail et teste les modules d'une
future station orbitale et développe des
programmes satellitaires ils sont en
train d'installer à vostotchny en russie
le cosmodrome qui remplacera baïkonour
et leur permettra de travailler beaucoup
plus efficacement leur développement
futur viendra sans doute du militaire en
après la prise de conscience que
l'espace était devenue indispensable
pour un certain nombre de techniques
allant des télécommunications à la
météorologie ou à l'observation et en
application de l'article 189 du traité
de lisbonne l'europe s'est dotée d'une
politique spatiale depuis l'union a
lancé des programmes comme copernicus ou
galileo quel système de navigation par
satellite le plus précieux au monde
pourtant la plupart des européens
l'ignorent et utilise son concurrent
américain gps à l'évidence le secteur
spatial qui emploie 230 mille salariés
et génère de 46 à 50 4 milliards d'euros
par an soit près de 10% du produit
intérieur brut de l'union européenne est
méconnu est mal utilisée par nos
concitoyens
pourtant il possède un potentiel réel
pour notre économie en offrant en aval
au delà des télécoms une grande variété
de services dans les domaines les plus
divers de l'agriculture de précision à
la gestion des crises
comme le rappelle le député massimiliano
salini dans un excellent article publié
par la fondation robert schuman
aujourd'hui comme l'écrit michel cabirol
dans la tribune des satellites
d'observation civile comme le système
pléiade d'airbus ps ont une résolution
inférieure à 30 cm ils permettent de
faire des études depuis l'espace sur
l'état des cultures
permet d'identifier de manière précise
les zones présentant une croissance ou
une végétation différentes les données
satellitaires génèrent les cartes de
prescription pour une utilisation
optimale des engrais des pesticides et
de l'irrigation
bien sûr pour éviter le gaspillage
réduire la pollution des sols ou de
l'eau et réduire l'empreinte carbone des
exploitations toutes ces données
d'origine spatiale peuvent être intégrés
aux informations locales aux données
météorologiques et aux données
historiques sur la production des
différentes parcelles on peut ainsi lire
à refuser les temps et les zones de
récolte et grâce à des modèles
agronomique faire des estimations
prévisionnelles sur les rendements des
cultures ici
le défi consiste à permettre aux plus
petites exploitations agricoles
d'utiliser ce type de technologie comme
ceux ci commencent à se faire en espagne
et en italie et technologies spatiales
offre également des informations pour la
planification et la surveillance des
infrastructures grâce à l'analyse
interférométrique basé sur les données
spatiales du radar il est possible de
mesurer en temps réel des déformations
mini métriques de structures comme les
barrages les ponts les bâtiments ou des
déplacements du sol dues aux variations
thermiques pouvant aller jusqu aux
glissements de terrain ainsi en
intégrant l'analyse satellitaire dans
les modèles 3d à haute résolution
il devient possible de fournir des
informations détaillées
pour la conservation de nos biens
culturels et historiques et de générer
des modèles d'évolution de leurs
dégradations dues aux phénomènes
environnementaux
peu de gens savent que l'observation de
la terre
génère aussi des analyses sur la qualité
de l'environnement
c'est ainsi que nos villes peuvent
bénéficier des technologies
satellitaires pour des services comme
par exemple la détection des fuites au
ou des canalisations de chauffage
l'identification des abus en matière de
construction ou d'environnement ou
encore prévenir les situations critiques
liées à l'instabilité
hydrogéologique tout ceci est obtenu à
partir des mesures réalisées par les
différents types de satellites qui
tourne au dessus de nous et qui se
retrouvent sur le même type d'orbité en
2010 il y avait environ
200 satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille pour les satellites
dits actifs
et en 2030 il y en aura plus de 100
milles autour de la terre
disposés pour l'essentiel dans des
configurations particulières
les fameuses constellation selon un
article de nature
plus de 29 mille satellite
morceaux de fusées et autres débris
suffisamment gros pour être suivie
depuis le sol terrestre
sont actuellement en orbite autour de la
planète des plus petits débris se
comptant par millions or
à une vitesse orbitale de 7 à 8 km par
seconde
même le plus petit objet peut avoir des
conséquences redoutables
c'est ainsi que la station spatiale
internationale
a dû manoeuvrer pour éviter un débris
six heures avant le lancement de la
récente mission crew 3
est déjà en mai elle avait été heurté
par un débris indétectable qui a mis
hors d'usagé
un de ses bras mécanique on comprend
pourquoi l'inquiétude augmente chez tous
les experts avec les lancements de
constellation de nano satellites
alors que les lancements de satellites
militaires se multiplient et que
l'encombrement des orbites autour de la
terre se densifie
la russie a testé la destruction depuis
une base militaire terrestre du vieux
satellite cosmos 1408 il en est résulté
un nuage de plus de 1000 débris spatiaux
obligeant les sept astronautes à bord de
la station spatiale internationale à
rejoindre en urgence leurs vaisseaux par
crainte d'une collision alors au delà de
la gesticulation médiatique contre le
tir russe il faut se souvenir
que les chinois en 2007
puis les américains en 2008
et les indiens en 2019 ont fait la même
chose
et que cet ajout aux multiples débris
existant doit donc être relativisé bugue
lewis le chef du groupe de recherche en
astronautique de l'université de
southampton
a indiqué récemment que le risque de
collision ne cesse d'augmenter depuis
les premiers lancements des milliers du
mini satellites du projet starlink en
mai 2019 chaque semaine ils sont
impliqués dans près de 700 rencontres
rapprochées d'engins spatiaux
qui oblige à réaliser des manoeuvres
d'évitement coûteuse en carburant comme
l'indiqué mme boher dans les échos il
faut agir vite car les risques
d'accident vont se multiplier
on estime qu'en 2030 on aura
vingt mille débris très problématique
dans la bande la plus utilisée de la
basse altitude là où se situera
l'essentiel des constellations
d'observation ou de télécommunication
et c'est pourquoi
à l'occasion du forum de paris sur la
paix
l'initiative nette zéro space a été
lancé par les européens considérant que
l'espace est un bien commun
elle demande la mise en place d'urgence
de règles du jeu afin de ne pas polluer
l'orbité basse avec davantage de débris
et la nettoyer pour permettre son
utilisation durable
alors on trouve aux côtés du cnes
eutelsat arianespace l'entreprise
chinoise chez eux et stl chang hwan
satellite les services européens de
surveillance spatiale le sst diverses
start up mais pas les américains
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
françois martin président du club hec
géostratégie à qui j'ai demandé de bien
vouloir réagir et compléter mon
interprétation françois tout d'abord
bonjour bonjour à l'art et bienvenue
dans la source
pour cet échange que j'espère
intéressant pour nos auditeurs et
téléspectateurs
aujourd'hui comment vois-tu les enjeux
pour le spatial civil
alors tout d'abord comme tu l'a appelé
le l'essentiel de l'aventuré
c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique ni laventure du service
même si les services attendus sont
immenses aussi bien sur le plan du gps
que l'agriculture comme tu l'a rappelé
ou la gestion de l'eau de l'écologie etc
mais c'est d'abord une recherche de
supériorité stratégique
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que ce sont des
grands oligarques américains qui se sont
lancé là dedans ou des états parce qu'il
faut bien voir que celui qui contrôle la
transmission ont fait est celui qui
contrôle le pouvoir est celui qui tire
l'argent depuis toujours tu sais que ce
sont les contrôles des routes ou bien
des ports ou bien des défilés ou bien
des estuaires où des montagnes ou
d'école qui font la puissance
aujourd'hui on a bien vu avec l'internet
que celui qui génère les flux en fait
est celui qui maîtrise la puissance et
bien en fait
cette développement du civil c'est
l'étape supérieure de l'internet
c'est-à-dire après la maîtrise des flux
c'est la maîtrise des tuyaux si je puis
dire des instruments qui transmettent
les flux voilà c'est ça en fait qui est
le l'enjeu qui est là derrière et c'est
pour ça que les valorisations sont aussi
importantes alors l'autre chose que je
voulais rajouter à ça c'est qu'en fait
le système et hybrides en fait tu as dit
dans ton propos que le système était
séparé entre chez les américains entre
le civil et le et le et le militaire on
voit bien avec l'exemple de l'homme
masque que en fait le système est
hybride est complètement c'est à dire
que le civil sert le militaire et c'est
la force des américains d'être capable
de rap de récupérer
l'initiative du privé pour servir les
intérêts de la puissance publique et de
la puissance militaire ce que nous en
europe nous sont moins capables de faire
puisque nous sommes pas capables
d'aligner en fait une grande entreprise
oligarchique et un grand état derrière
nos projets sont multi étatiques et
c'est ça qui rend cet alignement un peu
plus difficile voilà ce que je pense du
public justement dans cet esprit je
continue ce que tu viens de dire on a
l'impression quand même que derrière
tout ça le militaire prend de plus en
plus d'importance au niveau du spatial
à moins bien sûr d'abord on sait depuis
snowden que en fait le civil sert les
oligarchies servent la puissance
publique et la puissance militaire c'est
la raison pour laquelle elles sont pas
démantelée et puis d'autre part le le
militaire on peut dire c'est là c'est là
c'est la deuxième phase 2 de cette pièce
c'est à dire que les enjeux ni des
terres en fête son sont phénoménaux donc
évidemment
les militaires ont tout intérêt à se
servir alors tu as d'un côté une
puissance hybride et je dirais que la
puissance américaine et puis d'un autre
côté tu as des états qui sont des
puissances autoritaire qui sont capables
de et militaires et qui accorde beaucoup
d'importance aux militaires et qui sont
capables de générer beaucoup d'argent
pour ce faire et nous le problème que
nous avons en europe c'est que nous
sommes entre les deux nous sommes pas
suffisamment libre je dirais une
puissance hybride libéral est pas non
plus des régimes autoritaires pour
pouvoir source est suffisamment d'argent
d'accord écoute merci françois pour
toutes ces éclairages et ses apports que
tu viens de donner parce que ils sont
ils sont très instructives dans la
mesure où effectivement on a une vision
du spatial qui est un une vision un peu
partiel et partial je dirais un et grâce
grâce au coup de projecteur qu'on peut
donner ça permet de mieux comprendre la
réalité de qui est en train de se passer
dans lesquels comme tu le disais mon
dieu l'europe a pris quand même un
certain nombre de problèmes auxquels
elle doit faire face alors je trouvais
rajouter une petite chose peut-être
c'est qu'en fait les gens qui se rendent
pas compte que en fait si tu veux dans
dans les étapes supérieures de la guerre
successives qui a toujours eu en fait
les défensifs et les offensives qui se
sont succédé
à un moment donné je dirais que le
nucléaire c'est le lac à tes sens du
défensif parce que je t'attaque pas mais
si tu me touches je te tue donc et
l'espace est peut-être le premier
domaine est le seul et ça c'est
terrifiant qui est à la fois de défensif
et offensif parce que tu peux écouter
tout voir de ton adversaire tout savoir
et à un moment donné je ne sais pas si
aujourd'hui c'est capable on est capable
de le faire mais tu es capable de boue
et les communications spécifiques à
destination d'un pays et tu es capable
de vitrifier un pays complètement ou de
briser ses satellites et et tue le tue
le tue le tue en fait tu ne tue pas les
personnes mais tu le paralyse totalement
comme comme la morsure d'un cobra donc
on est je pense que c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les militaires
pousse à ce point là c'est que on est
vraiment au stade ultime de la guerre et
est dans quelque chose donc à mon avis
qu'on n'imagine pas encore
merci françois pour toutes ses atouts
ses apports 1 et à bientôt
l'analyse toute la concurrence mondiale
montre qu'il faut un budget spatial
ambitieux ce que nous venons d'évoquer
privilégiant la recherche et
l'innovation y compris par des vols
habités c'est essentiel non seulement
pour permettre à l'europe de jouer un
rôle au niveau mondial mais aussi pour
garantir l'autonomie stratégique de
l'union et la compétitivité de son
industrie
malheureusement
avec 13,2 milliards d'euros annoncée par
thierry breton pour la période 2021 2027
quand le budget annuel de la nasa en
2020 et est de 22,6 milliards de dollars
c'est le budget le plus faible des
grands opérateurs de toute manière
il ne pourra être efficace qu'en étant
accompagnée de la mise en place d'une
régulation internationale
pour rendre l'espace fiable est
assurable personne ne voulant payer son
nettoyage le risque auquel nous sommes
confrontés est d'arriver à une
saturation de l'orbize bases terrestres
la rendant
inutilisables et dangereuse à traverser
ainsi
des humains
auront réussi après avoir pollué la
planète à polluer l'espace proche avec
toutes les conséquences que l'on imagine
à bientôt
[Musique]